and the ethical dilemma I've always
struggled with in my career as a writer
is that um I tend to like the people
that I write about and I I I believe
it's my duty and job as a writer to
empathize with my subject not to get too
high flow and Dostoyevsky said it's very
easy to condemn the evildoer but the
challenge is to understand him or her
that's what I'm always trying to do and
I I sometimes end up favoring my
subjects too much and then I have to be
Stern with myself and say ethically it's
my job to dig out the nasty truths and
to tell them as well so that's what I
try to do
I almost invariably fall out of favor
with the people I write about my first
book on Saudi Arabia was banned I am
told this new book I've just written on
Saudi Arabia will be banned one of my
most successful books I went to live in
Detroit Michigan and wrote about the
Ford family and that was a wonderful
experience to sort of live in a big old
grimy American city although I could
sentimentally afford to say that because
I was going to go away and I didn't have
to live with the problems of the Rust
Belt I thought I'd painted a wonderfully
sympathetic portrait of the Ford family
but they haven't spoken to me from that
day to this and I can live with that
that's you know that's part of the the
job that being a writer there's a
falseness to it you know you you you
meet someone you creator I'm you
genuinely liked them but there's an
element of facsimile in the friendship
that you are creating because it's going
to end the moment the the interview is
over and you have to understand we list
a'kla I interview people to get
something out of them and they give me
interviews because they want something
out of me weed and does that bargaining
compromise in in every transaction the
right or journalist carries out